Dylan malany was paid of
$185,000 by Bud Light captive number8
they facilitate connections of
influencers and companies exclusive
audio that we have here involving
Captivate confirms that there was Panic
we also have a zero tolerance policy of
talking to press about our clients um
competitors or any internal matters the
issue isn't that your relationships are
kept private the issue that we have is
when you lie and the media uses that to
then Gaslight conservatives the reason
they did that was to try and convince
you that your boycotts don't work you
reacted perfectly appropriately and it
worked and you can continue to do it and
it will continue to work despite what
budlight Dylan malan or Captivate tells
you